The solutions for x are 3 plus or minus 4 root 3, all divided by 2 great
algebra work for getting that one correct. First we want to isolate the square
by adding 48 to both sides of our equation. So, we'll keep this squared
quantity on the left and we'll have positive 48 on the right. Next we take the
square root of both sides and indicate the plus or minus root here. This square
root undoes our square so we're left with the quantity 2x minus three. On the
right we still just have plus or minus root 48. We add three to both sides to
isolate our 2x, and then we divide both sides by 2, this coefficient. When we
divide both sides by 2 we're left with 1x on the left and 3 plus or minus root
48 divided by 2 on the right. Next we just simplify the square root of 48 to
get this answer. Keep in mind you could divide 2 into each of these terms. This
would give us x equal to 3 halves plus or minus 2 root 3. If you list your
answers like this, or if you list your answers like this, they're both correct.